through the tiny opening they used to
pull the injured caver out a team
heading back in to retrieve kit left
behind during the rescue
they showed us the route that takes them
deep under the ground
back towards the maze of tunnels where
they spent hour after hour carefully
carrying the man to safety
after a tense few days there's pride in
a job well done uh first of all how's
everyone feeling uh it's fantastic
success uh a lot of work put on by loads
of people and it's been very good relief
that the
casualty was out and elated that he was
still in
a very good
mental state for the amount of injuries
that he had
it was the longest stretcher carry in
british cave rescue history requiring
skill and patience to get the man out
safely
this was the final stretch of the
journey out of the cave system reached
after more than 50 hours of rescue work
which took the team through narrow
passages running water up vertical
climbs and all this with a seriously
injured man on a stretcher
and this is where he'll have finally
been able to see the exit a glimpse of
the outside world will have been so
welcome after more than two days stuck
underground
he was carried out protected by an
orange tarpaulin in good spirits his
rescuers say despite a suspected broken
leg and jaw fractured ribs and a deep
cut on his chin
only once he was in the vehicle did they
allow themselves to celebrate
[Applause]
steve thomas was right next to the man
as he finally emerged from the cave
it was the best place to be at the best
time it was the best moment of the whole
thing because
he wasn't in the cave any longer it was
like the threshold between being in the
cave and out of it really special moment
what did you say to him
you're out of the cave mate what did he
say he didn't say anything but he he
reacted he was yeah he was clearly
aware and happy
we now know more about how he was
injured he went into the cave on
saturday lunchtime around 250 metres in
some boulders gave way a rescue call was
made at 2 10 p.m at this point he was
about 60 meters underground
around 3 30 pm the rescue mission began
when they reached him they realized they
couldn't go back it was too narrow for
the stretcher
so throughout sunday and monday they
took the longer route up to the top
entrance where he emerged on monday
evening at 7 45
for the team it's mission accomplished
the life saving kit cleaned and ready in
case they need it again
becky johnson sky news in the brecon
beacons